Guten Abend.
Mein Name ist Eiloghan.
Ich bin hier der zuständige Arzt für Sie und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Analympic-Specuren.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ja, Hauptsache, jemand guckt nach mir.
Ja, okay. Also ich werde zuerst ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Dann kommen wir sofort auch zu Ihren Beschwerden.
Wie heißen Sie der?
Ja, bitte.
Ich heiße Paul Lüders.
Paul Lüders.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Nachname stabbieren?
Ja, Lü, also U-Umlaut.
D-E-R-S.
Okay.
Herr Lüders, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 69.
Ich bin im 23. März 55.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Im Ausgang, das steht 1,79.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das immer noch bin.
Ein bisschen wird man ja kleiner mit dem Alter.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zurzeit, Herr Lüders?
Ich wiege noch 74 Kilo.
74.
Haben Sie Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Ja, also ich vertraue kein Jod.
Das weiß ich.
Und dann gibt es ein Schmerzmittel, das ich nicht vertrage.
Und das heißt Novalgien.
Das darf ich nicht nehmen.
Okay, also wie äußert sich die Novalgien-Allergien,
wenn Sie das einnehmen?
Ja, also ich kriege da richtig einen starken Hautausschlag
oder habe das natürlich nur einmal erlebt.
Und ich habe auch so ein bisschen Luftnot bekommen, ja.
Und wenn Sie Jod essen, also was passiert bei Ihnen?
Ja, also bei Jod, das ist eigentlich so äußerlich,
wenn ich, also früher mal, wenn man so Jod auf eine Wunde getan hat,
oder so, habe ich immer gemerkt, dass es schlechter wird.
Da habe ich eben auch Hautausschlag bekommen.
Komm, alles klar.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihr Hausärztin?
Das ist Herr Dr. Schmidt.
Ja, Dr. Schmidt.
Also am Ende 2?
DT.
Okay.
Also Herr Lüders, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was führt Sie zu uns?
Also ich habe eigentlich schon die ganze Zeit immer so Schmerzen,
so Bauchschmerzen, dass das so drückt bei mir im Bauch.
Und ja, ich bin eigentlich schon lange ein bisschen schlecht drauf.
Und meine Frau hat immer schon gesagt, geh doch mal zum Arzt.
Und ja, also ich habe so ein bisschen Probleme,
dass ich manchmal Durchfall habe.
Und dann habe ich wieder, kann ich tagelang nicht auf die Toilette gehen.
Und dann ist mit einmal wieder Durchfall.
Und ja, in letzter Zeit schmeckt es mir, also überhaupt nicht.
Ich mag gar nicht essen.
Und das ist eigentlich schon lange und fühle mich immer so schlapp.
Und also, was es mir überhaupt nicht schmeckt,
das habe ich früher so gern gegessen.
Ich habe früher so gerne Fleisch gegessen.
Aber das mag ich jetzt, also überhaupt nicht mehr.
Und ja, und jetzt heute Morgen war etwas ganz Komisches.
Und da hat meine Frau da gesagt, also heute musst du aber wirklich mal
jetzt zum Arzt gehen.
Da wartest du nicht länger.
Und dann bin ich halt direkt hier zu Ihnen gekommen.
Und zwar hatte ich so ganz, mein Stuhlgang sah so ganz schwarz aus.
Das war mir dann doch ein bisschen unheimlich.
Also Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen, Herr Rüders, zu uns zu kommen.
Also seit wann haben Sie Bauchschmerzen?
Ja, dass die Bauchschmerzen so sind, eigentlich seit zwei Wochen so ungefähr.
Zwei Wochen.
Also sind Sie schlimmer geworden oder ist es?
Ja, so ein bisschen mehr ist das geworden.
Ja, aber eigentlich ist es noch erträglich.
Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass ich das überhaupt nicht aushalten kann.
Okay, Herr Steher.
Könnten Sie bitte genau zeigen, wo sind die Schmerzen?
Also obelbe Zeit.
Also in der Mitte würde ich sagen.
Und wo die Rippen so auseinandergehen.
Ja, in den Dreieck.
Da würde ich sagen, sitzen die Schmerzen.
Ja, okay.
Also wir können Oberbauchschmerzen.
Ja, so kann man das wohl beschreiben.
Also fühlen Sie sich die Schmerzen mehr als rechtsseitig oder linksseitig?
Ich würde sagen, die sind in der Mitte.
Also Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie also Druckgefühl im Bauch haben.
Also würden Sie die Schmerzen auch drücken?
Ja, so würde ich das nennen.
Als drücken beschreiben.
Könnten Sie die...
Also wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzstelle, wobei ein sehr leichter und zehn sehr starker Schmerzen entspricht?
Ja, also...
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen eigentlich?
Es ist nur so ein dauerndes Druckgefühl, vielleicht so vier bis fünf, würde ich sagen.
Also Herr Rüders, strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus oder sind die immer da?
Die sind eigentlich an dieser Stelle, also die strahlen jetzt nicht nach oben aus, irgendwie in den Hals oder so.
Und sie strahlen auch nicht in den Bauch oder in die Leisten oder so aus.
Nee, die sind da oben im Bauch sind die.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Herr Rüders, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie manchmal Durchfall haben, nach dem Durchfall haben Sie verstocken.
Also wie lange dauert die Durchfallfälle?
Ja, das ist immer mal so ein Tag, wo ich dann drei, vier Mal hintereinander auf die Toilette muss und wo das so ganz flüssig ist.
Und dann ist wieder harte Ruhe und manchmal habe ich auch das Gefühl, dass es ganz lange dauert, bis ich endlich wieder auf die Toilette kann und dann fühlt man sich ja auch nicht gut.
Okay, ich verstehe. Also haben Sie im Durchfall Blutbemäck oder andere Veränderungen?
Nein, da sind immer nur Essenfräste und so Schleim, was bei Durchfall so ist.
Aber auffällig war jetzt eigentlich nur heute diese Geschichte, dass das so ganz schwarze aussah. Das war ja ganz furchtbar.
Okay, ich verstehe. Sie haben seit heute Morgen also schwarze Stuhlgang.
Ja, ich habe mir das erste Mal aufgefallen. Man guckt ja eigentlich schon und das merkt man ja auch.
Also ich meine, das habe ich noch nie so gesehen.
Herr Lübers, haben Sie gegen die Beschwerden irgendwelche Medikamente ein, wie zum Beispiel Paracetamol, Ibuprofen und so weiter?
Eigentlich habe ich nichts eingenommen. Als das angefangen hat mit diesem Druck, da habe ich manchmal einen kleinen Schnaps getrunken oder so in der Hoffnung, dass das hilft.
Das hilft ja manchmal bei dem Verdauen. Aber das hat auch nichts gebracht. Dann habe ich das lieber wieder gelassen.
Ich verstehe. Leiden Sie unter Üblichkeit oder Elvreschen?
Ja, also schlecht ist mir zur Zeit wirklich. Aber also schlecht und ja, dass ich so überhaupt gar keinen Appetit habe.
Und zweimal musste ich mich tatsächlich auch jetzt in den letzten Wochen übergeben, also in den letzten zwei Wochen.
Sie zwei Wochen, haben Sie zweimal erbrochen?
Ja.
Also wie sagt die erbrochen aus? Haben Sie Blutbemäck oder gelbische Farbbemäck?
Gelblich, sage ich. Und natürlich das, was man vorher gegessen hat.
Wenn man Tee getrunken hat, dann sieht das halt so komisch, bräunlich, gelblich aus.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Ja, also in meinem Alltag muss man schon zwei bis drei Mal in der Nacht auf die Toilette. Das ist schon dumm.
Also in der Nacht, meinen Sie, ja?
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Appetitlosigkeit haben.
Also haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Ja, ich habe viel abgenommen. Ich habe immer so 84 kg gewogen.
Und jetzt habe ich mich neulich mal auf die Waage gestellt.
Da war ich ganz erstaunt, dass ich nur noch 74 kg wiege.
Also in welchem Zeitraum haben Sie in der Zeit umgekehrt?
Ich kleele nicht oft auf die Waage.
Das ist bestimmt ein halbes Jahr her, dass ich mich zuletzt gewogen habe.
Das ist eine gute Information für uns.
Ja, aber ich habe dann immer gedacht, naja, das ist vielleicht ganz gut.
Ich habe ja auch Diabetes.
Und dann ist das ja immer ganz gut, wenn man nicht so viel wiegt.
Aber vielleicht ist das doch ein bisschen viel.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen viel.
Es sieht so aus, aber ich gucke gerne mal.
Haben Sie Schüttelfrost oder Nachtschweiß?
Nein, eigentlich schwitzen tu ich nicht in der Nacht.
Nein, und Schüttelfrost hatte ich auch nicht.
Super, schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, eigentlich bis auf dieses, dass ich in der Nacht mal auf die Toilette muss.
Und das ist schon seit 2 bis 3 Jahren,
dass ich dann zwischendurch mal aufstehen muss.
Ja, wenn ich dann erst mal wieder in der Bettliege,
dauert es oftmals einen kleinen Moment,
dass ich dann wieder einschlafen kann.
Aber normalerweise klappt das wohl.
Super.
Herr Lüders, ich würde gerne jetzt einfach Fragen zu Ihrer Vorrichtung stellen.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie...
Ich habe mir auch noch etwas zu tun.
Kann ich Sie sagen?
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie Diabetes mellitus haben.
Seit wann haben Sie Zuckerverfeind?
Ach, das ist schon 15 Jahre.
Ich nehme da jetzt schon lange Medformin.
Wie viel Medformin nehmen Sie?
Ach, was steht denn da drauf?
Ich nehme da immer morgens und abends eine.
Aber wie viel ist denn das?
Ich meine 800 steht da drauf, kann das sein?
Ja, ich kann das.
Leiden Sie auch irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen?
Noch mal bitte.
Leiden Sie auch irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen,
außer Diabetes mellitus, das meine ich.
Ja, in meinem Alter hat man natürlich einiges.
Mein Bedudruck ist ein bisschen hoch.
Das hat man vor fünf Jahren festgestellt.
Aber der ist jetzt nicht dramatisch hoch.
Aber da nehme ich keine Medikamente.
Ich muss da nur ein bisschen aufpassen.
Und außerdem habe ich also kräftige Atrose in den Knien
und in den Hüften.
Ich habe halt in der Autowerkstatt gearbeitet
und da war es immer kalt.
Das ist nicht gut für die Gelenke.
Außer Diabetes mellitus, Blutdruck, Knien und Hüfteatrose
haben Sie noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Ja, ich finde das reicht völlig.
Mehr muss ich wirklich nicht haben.
Okay, sind Sie schon einmal Operitoren?
Als Kind natürlich.
Klar, da habe ich die Mandeln rausbekommen.
Aber sonst habe ich eigentlich nie etwas gehabt.
Also nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein,
außer Medikamente?
Ja, also wenn ich mal zu stark Schmerzen habe,
wenn mir die Knie oder die Hüfte zu sehr weh tun,
dann, wenn ich irgendwie deswegen nicht schlafen kann
oder so, dann nehme ich wohl mal Ibuprofen ein.
Aber also das nehme ich nicht ständig.
Entstehen.
Herr, das rauchen Sie?
Ja, nicht mehr viel.
Also früher habe ich mal deutlich mehr geraucht.
Jetzt rauche ich nur noch so 10 Zigaretten vielleicht am Tag.
Aber viele Jahre lang habe ich ein ganzes Päckchen am Tag geraucht.
Seit wann rauchen Sie wirklich 10 Zigaretten?
Das ist jetzt so 10 Jahre her.
Wie lange haben Sie täglich 20 Zigaretten geraucht?
Ach, die ganze Zeit, als ich berufstätig war,
also bestimmt 30 Jahre.
Herr Lübers, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Aus erhalb Schnaps, oder?
Ja, also Schnaps, gönne ich mir mal am Abend
und dann trinke ich eigentlich auch so 2 Flassen Bühe am Abend, ja.
2 Flassen?
Jeden Tag?
Du gut wie jeden Tag, ja.
Ja, wobei jetzt, wie gesagt, in den letzten Tagen
hat mir der Schnaps überhaupt nicht geschmeckt.
Das habe ich dann gelassen.
Erstehe.
Herr Lübers, nehmen Sie bitte die nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen? Ich? Nein, nein, damit habe ich nie etwas zu tun.
Super, perfekt.
Leben Ihrer Eltern noch?
Oh nein, die sind schon lange zu rund.
Ja, die sind beide früh gestorben.
Woran sind Sie gestorben?
Ja, mein Vater hatte Darmkrebs
und der ist also wirklich gar nicht alt geworden
und meine Mutter, die hatte,
ich weiß nicht, ob das auch damit zusammenhängt,
dass der Vater so früh gestorben ist,
die hatte schwere Depressionen
und die hat sich dann
wenige Jahre später tatsächlich das Leben genommen, ja.
Verstehe, ist mir leid.
Also, in welchem Alter ist Ihr Vater verstorben?
Der war 65, gerade in Rente.
Ja, der war 65, gerade in Rente.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, Geschwister habe ich nicht.
Also, haben Sie schon mal
haben Sie schon mal beim Hausarzt
oder Gastrologen
Krebsvorsorge untersuchen
und machen lassen?
Ja, aber das ist schon lange her,
das war dann mal so Mode,
als ich 50 war oder 55 oder so,
aber jetzt länger nicht.
Also, war es, war alles in Ordnung?
Ja, war es ja klar, ja.
Super.
Herr Blüters, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Meine Frau hat mich gedrängelt, dass ich mal hierher komme,
aber ich bin nicht verheiratet.
Sie haben schon gesagt, sorry,
haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, aber die sind schon erwachsen natürlich, ne?
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, ja, klar, ja, die sind gesund, die sind ja noch jung.
Also, Sie haben gesagt,
dass Sie in einem Autowerkstatt arbeiten.
Ja, jetzt bin ich ja schon lange in Hessen.
Ja, aber ich habe in der Autowerkstatt gearbeitet,
ja, ich war ausgebildeter KFZ Mechaniker.
KFZ Mechaniker.
Okay, Herr Blüters, ich habe alle meine wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Haben Sie Fragen an mich,
oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, also ich habe Ihnen ja noch viel erzählt,
was mich natürlich interessiert, wie es jetzt weitergeht,
woran liegt denn das und was kann man tun
und ob es gefährlich ist.
Und ja, das möchte ich natürlich alles gerne wissen.
Ja, natürlich, also, ja, ich kann Ihnen zurzeit nicht zu viel sagen.
Herr Blüters, ich muss Sie erst mal körperlich untersuchen,
dann werde ich Blut abnehmen,
dann ein paar Massnahmen durchführen,
zum Beispiel Bauchurtraschall.
Aber das tut nicht weh, ne?
Nein, nein, das ist Schmetzfreies- und Risikoeilmesterverfahren.
Das klingt gut, ja.
Ja, also nach der Ergebnisse kann ich Ihnen mehr sagen.
Vielleicht nach der Ergebnisse brauchen wir andere Massnahmen.
Also ich werde Ihnen Schritt für Schritt informieren,
also darüber informieren.
Das klingt gut, ja, Schritt für Schritt klingt vernünftig, ja.
Vielen Dank.
Danke schön, ich denke, das ist sehr gut gemacht.
Ja, sehr schöne Anamese gemacht, ja, wunderbar.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Die Reise an diese ist gefragt oder?
Die haben Sie in der letzten Zeit nicht gefragt, tatsächlich.
Die haben Sie in der letzten Zeit eine Reise auswandgemacht?
Nein, er war nicht weg.
Die zweite Frage ist, haben Sie ein Fieber gemerkt?
Ah, hat er nicht ausdrücklich gefragt, er hat nur nach Nacht,
Schweiß und Schüttelfrost gefragt, ne?
Aber ich habe mich nicht gemessen, aber fieberig fühle ich mich nicht.
Okay.
Hab ich ein bleistiftformiger Stuhl gemerkt?
Bleistiftformig?
Es ist jetzt stuhl dünner geworden.
Also wie gesagt, manchmal habe ich Durchfall und manchmal bin ich halt verstopft.
Ja, aber mit einem Bleistift habe ich nichts zu tun gehabt, nee.
Okay, eine...
Okay.
Ich weiß natürlich, was Sie meinen, aber...
der Patient weiß es nicht.
Also vorher war Ihr Stuhlgewohnheiten ganz in Ordnung, ja?
Wie letzte zwei Wochen?
Nein, das geht schon viele Wochen so, dass ich immer mal wieder Durchfall und Verstopfung habe.
Das ist schon lange Zeit.
Seit zwei Wochen tun der Bauch weh.
Ah, okay. Seit wann haben Sie diese Stuhlveränderung?
Monatelang, also das ist mir schon lange aufgefallen, ne?
Ich denke schon, können wir als Jahresgeschef hier anfangen?
Ja.
Gut.
Bitte schön.
Guten Abend Frau Erzdin.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patient aufgenommen, den ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Haben Sie gute Zeit für mich?
Ja, natürlich. Wem haben Sie denn gesehen?
Ja, also Herr Paul Lüders ist ein 69-jähriger Patient, 1,79 m groß und 74 kg schwer.
Herr Lüders stellte sich heute wegen, seit zwei Wochen, seit zwei Wochen bestehender, druckender, zunehmender Epigastrialschmerzen ohne Alstralog Bayounsko.
Er berichtete, dass er einen Druckgefühl im Bauch hat.
Also die Schmerzintensität wurde mit vier bis fünf von zehn auf eine Schmerzskala bewertet.
Außerdem klagte er über Diarrheu und Obstpation, Attacke.
Also wenn er Diarrheu hat, dauert es also einen Tag.
Er musste in dieser Zeit drei oder vier Mal auf die Toilette gehen.
Also der Durchfall ist flüssig, gab es kein Blut.
Dann kommt Obstpation, Attacke. Also er hat ein paar Tage Ruhe, dann kommt Verstopfen.
Also der Svater berichtete, der Svater gab er an, dass er seit heute Morgen Melania hat.
Also er hat Melania erst mal gehabt.
Erstmal nicht beschrieben.
Also Fernner erwähnte er, dass er Müdigkeit und Emesis und Nausea hat.
Er musste in den letzten Wochen zweimal erbrochen.
Erbrechen, ja, erbrechen übergeben.
Erbrechen war unaufgängig.
Auf Nachfrage hat er berichtet, dass er mit 50 Jahren eine Vorsorgeuntersuchung machen lassen hat.
Er macht Lies oder gemacht hat.
Ja, gemacht hat.
Er leidet in der vegetative Anamnese in Appetenz.
Er hat in den letzten sechs Monaten ungefähr 10 kg abgenommen.
Außer dem leidet er an Nüchterie, 2-3 Mal in der Nacht.
Also bekannte Vorerkrankungen sind Diabetes mellitus seit 15 Jahren.
Arterielehypertone seit 5 Jahren.
Dagegen hat er keine Medikamente, nur kontrolliert.
Aber den Blutdruck für Diabetes nimmt er da was?
Also gegen Diabetes nimmt er mit Rormin 800 mg, 2 Mal Morgen.
Also andere Vorerkrankungen sind Gonartros und Coxartros.
Und Beninprostatiperblasen.
Also in der Kindheit wurde eine Tonselektomie vorgenommen.
Er nimmt bei Bedarf über Profen und regelmäßig mit Rormin.
Außer dieser Medikamente nimmt er nichts.
Er raucht seit 10 Jahren täglich 10 Zegaretten.
Früher hat er 30 Jahre lang täglich 20 Zegaretten geraucht.
Also wir haben hier 35 Päckchen.
In der Familienanamnese gab er bei meinem Vater Darum Karcinom.
Er ist mit 85 Jahren an Darum Krebs gestorben.
Ja, Fachbegriff?
Kolonkarcinom.
Und seine Mutter liegt an Depressionen.
Also sie hatte Suizid.
Suizid?
Also im Rahmen eines Suizids verstorben.
Als sozialanamnest ist er verheiratet.
Er ist jetzt in Ruhe statt.
Früher hat er als KVZ Mechaniker gearbeitet.
Was?
KVZ Mechaniker.
Kraftfahrzeug.
Ja, Automechaniker.
Nach dem ananistischen Angaben habe ich einen Verdacht auf Kolonkarcinom.
Was spricht dafür?
Gewichtsabnahme, 10 kg in letzten 6 Monaten.
Also spricht für Kolonkarcinom.
Außerhalb haben wir Familien vorgeschichte.
Also seinen Vater liegt an Kolonkarcinom.
Wo sind deine Schmerzen lokalisiert?
Also er hat eher Schmerzen.
Epigastrialbereich lokalisiert.
Ja, das spricht gegen Kolonkarcinom.
Also das spricht für vielleicht Magankarcinom.
Der ist auch differentialdiagnose.
Was könnte differentialdiagnostisch noch sein?
Also wenn ich es kühle, kann ich das rein.
Also wir haben hier Oberbau, Bullutungen.
Was könnte es noch sein, wenn man noch ein bisschen höher denkt als den Magen?
Es ist ein Farbuskarcinom.
Obwohl er dafür eigentlich keine Symptomatik schildert.
Was machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit den Patienten?
Ich werde es mal den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Was gucken Sie, was tasten Sie? Worauf achten Sie besonders?
Also bei der Inspektion überprüfe ich die Hautfarbe.
Also er hat Bullutungen.
Also kann er eine gelbische Part der Änderungen haben.
Ja, aber das kann er haben.
Also bei der Palpation fasste ich den ganzen Bauch ab.
Erst mal überprüfe ich die Lünftmärkte.
Also in der Leichtbereich.
Im grünen Bereich.
Also ich werde digital untersuchen.
Ich muss das klären, ob es Melanahe hat oder nicht.
Ja, gut.
Das machen Sie denn noch?
Das machen Sie an Blutuntersuchung und an technischen Untersuchungen?
Also in der Blutuntersuchung überprüfe ich also Blutbild.
Also Nierenwerte, Leberwerte, Tunermarkere, Tunermarkere und Gerührungspaktoren.
Auf alle Fälle, ja.
Also ich gucke auch die Blutgruppe.
Auf alle Fälle? Genau, ja.
Weil brauchen wir Blutverkaufsstation.
Was machen Sie noch für Untersuchungen, weiß er technisch?
Also ich werde erst mal Bauch, ob es auch Abdomenzone gibt.
Also ich kann damit sehen, ob es einen Raumförderung gibt.
Oder aktive Blutungen.
Man kann sagen, wenn es starke Blutungen gibt.
Ich werde Koloskopie und Endoskopie büchern.
Also das ist wirklich...
Das ist wirklich...
Also so fängt es sich um den Endoskopie.
Ja, und was erwarten Sie?
Beide ÖG erwarten ich,
eine aktive Blutung,
wahrscheinlich Magendeich,
Oberen Magendeich,
oder hinteren ÖG.
Ja, gut.
Okay, gut.
Dann untersuchen Sie bitte den Herrn...
Ich habe einen neuen Namen, Herr Lüders.
Ja, den Herr Lüders.
Halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden,
was mit ihm tatsächlich los ist.
Und auch, was wir dann als nächstes Schritt mit ihm anfangen,
was wir mit ihm machen.
Ja, gut.
Ja, schöne Anamnese.
Schöner Arztbericht.
Ich würde mal sagen, haben Sie gut gemacht.
Dr. Gündes hat zwischendurch einmal reklamiert,
das, was ich auf dem letzten Mal schon gesagt habe.
Ja, also.
Und also...
Ja, also...
Das ist extrem häufig bei Ihnen.
Das ist wirklich extrem.
Das wird wahrscheinlich...
Ich mache es selber auch.
Ich weiß es.
Das ist enorm schwer, so etwas abzustellen.
Das haben Sie sich angewöhnt.
Und da muss man schon sehr kontrolliert sprechen,
um das so ganz zu vermeiden.
Das ist wirklich sehr, sehr kompliziert.
Und es gibt kaum jemanden,
der seine Sätze so formuliert,
ohne dass er zwischendurch mal macht.
Aber bei Ihnen ist es schon wirklich auffällig.
Das Problem ist, wenn Sie ganz gezielt versuchen, das zu vermeiden,
werden Sie wahrscheinlich in so eine stockende Sprache kommen,
dass es auch nicht gut ist.
Aber versuchen Sie es im Alltag vielleicht,
ein bisschen abzuschalten und abzustellen.
Lesen Sie zum Beispiel jemandem etwas vor?
Oder machen Sie einen Schrift?
Ja, da habe ich selber schon wieder ein.
Machen Sie einen schriftlichen Bericht zu Ihrem Patienten
und lesen Sie den jemanden vor,
ohne dabei auch nur ein einziges Mal also zu sagen.
Dann suchen Sie es zumindest.
Es ist wirklich ein großes Problem,
wenn man sich so etwas angewöhnt hat, das abzuschalten.
Und natürlich hilft uns jedes Eh
so ein bisschen so eine kleine Nachdenkpause zu geben.
Und manchmal ist es ja auch richtig,
manchmal ist es auch richtig,
wenn ich das als Resümee zum Beispiel habe.
Ich habe das um das gemacht.
Also vermute ich, dass, ja, gut.
Das ist aber wirklich so von der Sprache her fast das Einzige.
Also umgangssprache ist bedeutet M.
Das hat keine Bedeutung.
Das ist nur ein Füllwort, was wir brauchen,
um nachzudenken und Luft zu holen.
Das hat überhaupt gar keine Bedeutung.
Geben wo ist mir eine falsche Zahl aufgefallen.
Ach ja, genau.
Der Vater ist nicht mit 85 gestorben,
sondern mit 65.
Ein kleiner Hörfehler.
Und daraufhin, weil der Vater so früh gestorben ist,
habe ich gesagt, hat die Mutter die Depression bekommen.
Wie kann man das sagen,
wenn ein Mann mit einem sie im Führsitz gemacht hat?
Ja, sie ist an den Folgen eines Suizids gestorben.
Können Sie wieder wiederholen?
Sie ist an den Folgen eines Suizids gestorben.
Das könnte man vielleicht sagen.
Oder sie hat sich das Leben genommen,
aber eigentlich sollte man den Begriff Suizid benutzen,
wenn man das einfach begriff.
Ja, und sonst haben sie eigentlich wirklich sehr vollständig
sowohl gefragt als auch wiedergegeben,
dass sie das nicht mehr so gut haben.
Was mir so ein bisschen gefehlt hat,
Sie haben gesagt, er hat sich vorgestellt,
haben Sie sehr schön mit allen Fachbegriffen,
Progredientes, Epigastral, Schmerzen, was auch immer.
Was Sie ein bisschen verspätet für meinen Geschmack gesagt haben,
dass er jetzt heute Morgen erstmals Melena bemerkt hat,
weil das der eigentliche Anlass war.
Der ursprüngliche Grund für seine Beschwerden mögen diese Bauchschmerzen gewesen sein.
Aber heute ist Ihnen eben etwas Besonderes aufgefallen.
Erstmalig Melena.
Und deswegen hat er jetzt sich entschlossen,
endlich hier in die Klinik zu kommen.
Also das hätte man vielleicht noch ein klein bisschen mehr betonen können.
Aber ansonsten würde ich mal sagen, war das gut.
Und was Sie nicht erwähnt haben beim Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch,
der Patient hat so gesagt, er hat früher gerne Fleisch gegessen
und das schmeckt ihm jetzt nicht.
Das ist eigentlich auch so ein klassisches Ding zur Beesymptomatik.
Ja, stimmt.
Aber wie gesagt, sonst wunderbar,
auch Fachbegriffe kamen gut.
Diabetes-Melitus könnte man vielleicht betonen, Typ 2.
Wahrscheinlich hat er Diabetes-Melitus Typ 2.
Trotzdem muss er mir das fragen.
Soll er mir das fragen?
Nein, aber man kann ja davon ausgehen,
dass es ein 2er-Diabetes ist,
wenn er das mit 55 bekommen hat.
Dann ist es kein 1er-Diabetes.
Aber ich würde das jetzt, würde ich halt immer als Arzt-Gespräch dazu sagen.
Das meine ich.
Aber sonst, Kokosatrose, Gonatrose, schön, alles gut gekommen.
Also, Resemée, es war gut.
Ja, von dieser sprachlichen Feinheit abgesehen, war es gut.
Danke schön.
Ich habe unsere letzte Simulation zugehört nochmal.
Und ich habe auch bemerkt, dass ich sehr oft, also nutze.
Ja, es ist permanent.
Ja, ich nicht.
Aber wie gesagt, was will man dagegen tun?
Sie haben sich das angewöhnt, so wie wir uns alle das L angewöhnt haben.
Ja, und ich versuche, etwas durchzulesen.
Ich kann deutlich durchlesen.
Aber wenn ich sprechen, muss ich denken.
Also, ich glaube, mein Kopf ist voll.
Wenn ich zielorientiert spreche, also nutze ich weniger.
Ja, es ist natürlich, es ist immer, diese Füllwörter sind immer eigentlich eine Chance zum Nachdenken.
Ja, und natürlich müssen wir in so einem Gespräch nachdenken, den Faden wiederfinden.
Was habe ich schon gefragt?
Was will ich noch fragen?
Ja, und manchmal ist es ja auch eine zulässige Zusammenfassung, wie gesagt.
Aber versuchen Sie es einfach nochmal bewusst im Alltagsgespräch nochmal zu vermeiden.
Haben Sie jemanden, dem Sie Ihre Geschichte nochmal erzählen können?
Was wird ich Partner, Freund, Freundin, mit dem Sie reden können, dem Sie erzählen können?
Der Patient hat sich heute bei mir vorgestellt, er piepapu.
Haben Sie jemanden, mit dem Sie das üben können?
Zu Hause.
Oh, jetzt steht Ihre Leitung.
Ich bin vor lauter Schreck.
Jetzt sind Sie wieder da.
Wir hatten einen Netzausfall.
Haben Sie jemanden, mit dem Sie das mal durchsprechen können?
Ja, ich habe meine Frau.
Ja, da siehst du.
Klar, ich muss die Frau, die Oberärztin spielen und ich muss Ihre Geschichte anhören.
Und jedes Mal, wenn Sie also sagen, dann soll sie Ihnen Shubs geben.
Okay.
Ja, das ist mir zu viel.
Versuchen Sie mal, das hinzukriegen.
Ich denke mal, das übt ein bisschen.
Stellen Sie Ihr Herrn Lüders nochmal in aller Ausführlichkeit vor, ohne also.
Ja, aber ansonsten glaube ich, dass das für die Prüfung keine Relevanz haben wird.
Sie verstehen alles und Sie können alles vermitteln, was man fragen kann.
Also, ich habe da eigentlich keine Sorgen.
Ja? Also, gut.
Ja, wir sehen uns übermorgen.
Ja, ja.
Und ansonsten wünsche ich Ihnen.